[Music]  to our coronavirus coverage a quick look  at our numbers so nevada's and clark  county's positivity rate have continued  to drop by the day right now they're at  14.1 percent and 13.2 percent meanwhile  the county is reporting 215 cases per  every one hundred thousand over the last  seven days that number needs to be below  100 for restrictions to ease up and of  course you can always scan this qr code  on your screen it'll take you straight  to the breakdown of our full covet  report on 8newsnow.com  and if you're interested in getting the  copic vaccine there are a number of  pop-up clinics scheduled for today one  is at catholic charities of southern  nevada from uh  until 1 pm excuse me so it's going on  right now and that's on las vegas  boulevard near owens you can find a full  list of all the vaccine clinics on eight  news now dot com